you know I'm always curious when the
person that complains about a capitalism
video I'm making about entrepreneurship
something like that about business to
person complaints capitalism is the
worst system and they're complaining on
their iPhone or their smartphone on
YouTube all started by capitalist which
by the way this is a complete different
perspective to give you for you to be
thinking about what is innovation do for
you well how many of you today watching
this actually like what you do for a
living how many you love your jobs do
you love what you do by the way
would you replace doing what you do
right now versus I don't know being a
farmer would you want to be a farmer
would you want to work on a farm let me
explain to you what the conditions of a
farmer is mosquito bites all day right
spiders you're working with dirt you're
sweating son maybe rain you got to work
you know you got to go through it now
you've got to be working 12-hour days
it's a lot of manual labor would you
want to be a farmer would you want to be
a farmer would you if you said no for
some of you that are watching st. Pat I
don't get the points here this pad want
us to go back to being farmers and
working in agriculture here's what I'm
saying to you in America during colonial
times 90% of all workers in America
worked in agriculture everybody was a
farmer everybody you would have been a
farmer today by the way in 1940 1% were
farmers in 1900's in America 41% of all
of us we'd be doing agriculture I
wouldn't be running an insurance company
right norsu you know doing vitamin
videos I'd be if on a farm I'm a pretty
big guy I can probably pick up a lot of
strawberries where I can probably go on
working pretty huh I'd be a farmer you'd
be a farmer dart all this stuff right
outside being around it but you're not a
farmer today today only 2% of people in
America are farmers we went from 90
percent to 41 percent to 2 percent today
are you glad are you glad are you glad
that there's not a farmers today what
happened there what happened there
that's called innovation the capitalist
said we can figure out a better way of
doing this let's get to work and because
of capitalists they figured out ways to
do it better they figured out ways to
make it more efficient and I gave you
the opportunity to have a different kind
of a job where you can work behind a
desk or whatever it is that you do out
there and you don't have to be outside
12 hours a day working hard
because of a capitalist figuring out a
way to add advancement and innovation
that gave me the opportunity to do what
you do today rather than being a farmer